hey everybody and welcome back to
nintendo treehouse live
i am demetrius and i'm joined with ethan
hello hey
and we're here to play shin megami
tensei five and i'm
so excited yeah i'm excited to love this
series
so why don't we start out ethan what is
shin megami tensei five
so uh shin megami ten say five a little
bit of a mouthful to say
i do love saying it though uh shin
megami ten say five
is the latest uh game in a really long
running
uh jrpg series um
this is a series that got its start uh
way back when
on the super famicom uh and
i've loved that this series has been
getting a lot of attention and
appreciation
um in the west uh outside of japan in
recent years
um and uh that this new game is is
coming to nintendo switch
um and before we dive in too much more i
mean can we just take a moment to
appreciate
this fantastic glorious hair that i wish
i had
our main character here um not not every
day that you get a character with such
fantastic hair yeah
you know what listen uh so
um you know just to just to talk about a
few of the the kind of defining features
of this series
um as you can see we've got kind of real
world elements
mashed together with the fantastical and
and the mythological as we will see
even in our character um you know but if
we look closely we see
things like uh japanese written on the
pavement here
um and uh we see uh you know
buildings are what look like buildings
and and buses and cars but
also everything uh seems to be in a bit
of a jumble um
things are not looking right not at all
clearly something
went wrong something's definitely gone
wrong um but that that
mix of of real world and uh fantastical
is definitely like a hallmark of shin
megami tensei
um picking up some some orbs here um
getting a nice little uh heal up on my
hp and my mp um and
i'm gonna stop by these nice little
vending machines which
it's great that these are still
operational oh you just need a drink
yeah just just something pick up a can
of juice it's really hot out
dust covered box okay that's its box
sure
uh fine use for it not what i typically
associate with vending machines but
um we are of course playing the japanese
version right now i'll be doing some
translation
as we go through demons are another uh
big part of the shin megami tensei
series and we're gonna meet one of them
right now
um you battle demons but you also do a
fair bit of talking with demons
and uh this demon is gonna tell us a bit
about where we are
so uh i think it was about 20 years ago
uh that uh this place uh became a new
netherworld all right um sounds
intriguing
um and up until that point uh humans had
lived here it was a world humans had
lived in
um and nobody really knows why it became
another world
okay so uh you know i could i could talk
to this demon because of the
the word balloon above its head but
we're actually being approached here and
i
think we're going to get in our first
battle that's right um
that uh that demon was on a mission oh
and he got two slots okay
so while ethan focuses here allow me to
explain the the battle system
it's what's known as the press turn
system and which is really
really cool it's essentially about
exploiting the enemy's weakness and
trying to find out what it is
and when you do you can actually get
extra turns
or actions back allowing you to continue
to attack or pressing the advantage
pressing turn so
really really fun stuff so what ethan
here is trying to find is the weakness
there we go oh yeah there's one
so we have an additional action back so
you'll see the turn will continue
on ethan's side allowing him to continue
attacking
what's really fun is if you're able to
figure out all of your enemies
weaknesses you can exploit them
and just attack non-stop or well not
non-stop but enough to
maybe even wipe them out before they can
even really attack you which is really
awesome
so let's see that was some slime on
slime uh battling there
um because i've got a slime in my party
um
and let's see i think you know the
weakness is i think fire yeah so this is
uh augie which is a fire ability um and
i can see so
down below i can see all these elemental
affinities um when i started against
that other enemy that i defeated
that was an enemy i hadn't encountered
before so they were all question marks
um turned out uh wind worked well
against uh
that enemy the slime has a bunch of
weaknesses so fire ice lightning wind
um are all it's weak against all of
those no i i just want to see you then i
wouldn't use fire on that particular ah
too late
no it's fine okay i was i was just
trying to min max here
you could have you could have used that
magazine got another turn took them both
because they were both weak that's right
okay
we're good we're fine okay we do call
you battle master d for a reason
um even though because i think this will
give you
oh wow okay because like the slime
fortunately has a lot of weaknesses so
you're kind of
you're good picking a lot of different
things but um okay so
i have actually leveled up here with my
my main character
um we get a kind of a look at the the
stat screen you see when you level up
um and one thing i'm going to get
is a point to put into one of my five
different um kind of abilities down here
so i have strength
endurance magic agility and luck
and my luck is currently just at eight
and so i'm gonna
use my point to bring that uh in line
with the rest of them
so we'll have nines across the board um
so i raised my luck there
let's see i hear i hear a demon
somewhere i think it was yeah okay it's
over oh up there in front of yeah there
you go you gotta pay attention to where
they are and
you know folks who are who are familiar
with this series will will notice that
for the first time with this game we're
able to see the enemies
uh on kind of the maps that i'm that i'm
making my way around
yep and since i just got into battle i'm
gonna run past this one
uh which i can do um you know by being
able to see it as opposed to having just
random battles
um run down here to this uh
kind of decrepit looking train track
situation
um again just kind of getting a view at
our
ruined surroundings it's clearly again
very strong yeah
surreal weird stuff going on
netherworld apparently some kind enemies
up there
i'm gonna keep on trucking down here
um these are looking good yep
um we're just gonna kind of make our way
through this little valley yeah and i
think there's some
yeah there's a couple demons coming up
here oh yeah
let's see those look like mandrakes yeah
i think so yeah yeah
i can also like use my sword to start
one of these battles
um and that'll make sure that that i get
to go first
which is great or not so much apparently
hold on
um so i was actually going to show this
off i had intended to anyway
um demon negotiation is you know
talking with demons like you do it's a
big part of the shin megami
tensei series and i was planning on
talking to this mandrake but
it started a conversation with me um
which i have not seen before so let's
see what it wants to say
so it's asking me for money right off
the bat
okay um if i give it money uh
how much money it'll overlook whatever
apparently i've done to offend it this
time 200 200
i've got 914 i'm gonna say go for it
ethan okay
yeah so i can agree or i can
say no um and say you know get out of
here
uh but we'll we'll agree this time
uh oh wait but it wants something else
see this is the problem always something
the problem with mandrakes wait it wants
more money
see okay now it wants 98 more
we got we got we got a a nice amount
okay
loosen the purse strings a little bit
more
it is still asking for more
money okay no no no
i think i think i actually misunderstood
that it said it said basically it'll see
me again
um let's you know okay let's try this
we're gonna try one more time because
that went unexpectedly but that's the
fun part though that's the negotiation
side you just don't
easily uh you know recruit demons you
actually have to think about how you're
going to interact with everyone it's
really really fun yeah
um so i'm going to i'm going to choose
talk from my my menu this time
and uh and do do the conversing from my
end
um so i know and yeah lost that money
and he just like was like okay i'm gonna
let you be
it was like what okay um so he's
approached
what are we gonna do okay so
we have a couple options here we can
just be quiet
kind of be quiet and and be silent we
can glare
uh or we can just not move so what do
you think
not react be silent
okay we'll take the silent approach
uh so wait are you saying
that i can't be near you
no so wait then you're saying we can't
be friends
oh no okay so negotiations have broken
down
um you never know what these these
demons are gonna say
um so while i i can't really negotiate
with my pixie and my slime so
i am gonna attack um because it is still
my turn
um and we'll see maybe we can continue
our negotiations but we also have
another demon too to talk to that's true
what i'm worried about is if they attack
the slime okay yeah they did not no i
know
okay pixie guy okay we're okay with that
we're okay with that uh a shocking
experience there
okay so um we are gonna try talking to
the
other mandrake and we'll see if we have
any other luck here what was the matter
it took all our money
i know bring that one back
okay so this mandrake is saying hey um
can i pull off your arms and legs
and this is basically my choices here
are no way or
only if i can do it back to you which
i'm not sure how that works but
what do you think i'll let this look
good for you i'm gonna say
hey only if i can do it back i would
agree
uh oh this so he's saying to me like oh
this
this one's got some this one's got some
fire this one's uh
all right yeah kind of feisty um so
if i were to die what would you do the
mandrake says and i can say
i wouldn't care or i'd be really sad or
bummed out
really sad yeah i don't see anything
back
okay well then be nice to me why don't
you
now what should i do it's saying it's
still wondering
um it wants just a little bit of rhp
just a little bit just a little bit okay
um we can always heal with our pixie
yeah sure um so yes again we have
options we can kind of play the tough
guy if we want
oh nine nine we can we can spare that
this one
oh my gosh okay 205
i mean that's go
we gotta stop now negotiating
okay huh i think that'll do it uh thanks
yes all right there we go so
as you can see 700. um negotiations with
demons as you might imagine are kind of
unpredictable
um but we convinced this mandrake to
join our party which is awesome
so now we've got a party for your table
is ready
and we are going to continue going
i guess um and
yeah the other director like just trying
to follow me we're not gonna let that
happen
um so we're gonna go down here yeah
you're good
you always gotta check though cause like
it's still coming um so i'm gonna talk
to this
this guy do love the the enemy design
uh in this game and this series in
general is fantastic
excellent excellent demon design so
humans uh lived
lived here uh for a long time um but
as you can see the uh this town's just
changed uh completely
and used to have buildings everywhere
um but now not so much um
so not sure oh yeah i know right i know
oh gosh i'm getting stuck you're good
okay
you're gonna look i'm watching you you
never know you never know
there's those in front of you look at
him look at him look at him stare at you
like
sup meat mugging
across the way okay so now we've got
this demon floating in this little pot
um so hey the battle that took place
here was
really incredible did you take part in
it uh i don't think so
wait you don't know about it this is the
all that that stuff that kicked off here
18 years ago
it was this this massive battle between
demons and angels
it was super incredible
but wait what side did end up winning it
says huh sounds like the way to the
party
all right what does this one have to say
oh oh oh oh oh
i see it i see it i see it look at that
too look at that
they're on their way don't look it's all
right all right hold on don't panic
yeah i do like that they let me have a
conversation though
um so let's see uh there is a massive
rock like guy up ahead i think i said
and if you try to battle him he's gonna
he's gonna stomp you in a second
that might be him up there yeah um
well i still think we should probably go
for it i do too step one is to get away
from yeah we gotta guys we're not
interested in finding them we want
another one
okay we're gonna we're gonna do our
little our little dash here which i love
um run away far away
they gave up that's good perfect take a
breather here at this uh
little vending machine stop um
we got another dust covered box
and another can of juice all right
that's good yeah
um so i guess
all right shall we bring on the
challenge we got this
massive rock guy up here okay ah that's
pretty big uh so i guess i'll try and
start the battle with
oh wow oh he doesn't sound happy oh nice
i think i got that in yeah i think he
did too okay
so we get to go first we do have the
four
uh four characters now right um now
let's assume that it's
it's a massive rock so what are you
thinking i've got lightning i've got
fire let's do fire okay
both fire so i don't know anything about
level 48
i don't know anything about this uh this
uh demon's uh
weaknesses what oh
okay so it is weak against fire
unfortunately it looked like that only
did
four damage which is not good um
does anyone need healing oh i guess
actually i can use
my pixie to heal herself
[Music]
pixie healed myself and
okay excellent and now it is
poison slime storm shall we try poison
yeah i'm gonna say
poison okay do that
fingers crossed miss that's no good
okay so then the mandrake gets to go
uh lightning and a regular attack i have
a feeling
i mean it's a rock are you thinking
lightning is no good yeah let's try
physical then okay we'll try a physical
attack
lisa didn't exist it didn't resist
but we do get to go a second time with
uh with the
our main character here because of that
that first attack it was weak against
maybe actually
i can keep this party don't try
lightning though too now if you want oh
that's true that's true i could have
that's fine
i'm able to keep going right so um
because i i got that weakness again
so what do you think attack here did we
try wind
we haven't tried wind yet i don't think
let's try that out
we've still got a question mark on wind
so
come on pixie okay three damage normal
damage
yeah all right here it goes
okay
see you on the other side we're still in
here we got this um still got three
standing which is pretty good
so you were saying maybe lightning just
to try yeah because
it's still a question mark i mean yeah
yeah go for it out of curiosity i have a
feeling it's gonna resist yeah
yeah okay i guess we should have seen
that coming um
slime what do you got do the poison
attack above uh
okay yeah let's try that one okay let's
try this one
still the same um elemental affinity i
think you might have
oh so weak it was weak it didn't look
like that did damage but uh it it was
weak against that
that's good yeah um mandrake
uh will it just attack again
this is a war of attrition here
um fire definitely i think is the way to
go
but with which each one of those you
know those attacks that uh
explode a weakness i get another turn
unfortunately i just don't know if i can
keep
keep that going much longer yeah i think
this is a valid effort though yeah okay
that missed again
listen let's see what happens here oh is
he just going right for you oh
whoa he targeted me straight yeah he was
one hit we're done
dang so yeah
and there's a look too at uh two of the
lead characters i know we had more info
about that ethan right yeah
so this um our main character uh in this
game is a human
uh fused with an unknown being um and we
kind of got a look at the both of them
there i mean that's that's it we ended
in a game over but but
that was shin megami tensei five and of
course there's always gonna be more
um and that was shin megami tensei five
and that comes out
on november 12th with pre-orders
starting on june
21st so definitely look forward to it
but don't go anywhere we'll be right
back with advance wars oneplus 2
reboot camp oh yeah see you soon